[主播] 好，谢谢，谢谢。
[主播] 谢谢，好啊。
[主播] 有朋友说让东东老师回来。
[主播] 让东东老师休息。
[主播] 我不信。
[主播] 是，你不要。
[主播] 真的让东东回来。
[主播] 让东东这种帅哥多出现在我们面前几次。
[主播] 大家现在对我要求已经越来越苛刻了。
[主播] 现在说董宇辉来迟了，请扣工资。
[主播] 我们帮你记下了。
[主播] 还帮我记下了。
[主播] 现在要把我法办了，是吧？
[主播] 好。
[主播] 当年一起看星星的时候，叫人家小甜甜啊。
[主播] 现在新人胜旧人。
[主播] 要把人家法办了。
[主播] 行吧。
[主播] 错付了啊。
[主播] 我们今天晚上的书很多。
[主播] 今天晚上的这个也有一些好的产品。
[主播] 美的窒息的唐诗宋词诗经一共我十万单。
[主播] 这个吗？
[主播] 这个。
[主播] 正好。
[主播] 来，这本书直播间里的朋友之前没有拍过的，大家可以继续拍了，顿顿这两天给大家读了很多的诗经。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友可以拿著这个，买著这个书呢，等顿顿跟大家一起去读诗经。
[主播] 我特别喜欢喜欢这个唐诗宋词啊，因为我这个确实文化水平有限啊。
[主播] 文化有限公司吗？
[主播] 所以呢，这个诗经呢，我确实读的少一些，但是我对于唐诗宋词还是比较喜欢的。
[主播] 许渊冲老师的，之前也给大家讲过他很多的这种翻译。
[主播] 其中像这里头非常经典的春江花月夜，张若虚。
[主播] 大家读到春江花月夜的时候，觉得真的，是怎么写出这样的绝片？
[主播] 你在后来很难再能找到一个篇幅如此长，但是每一句都又精练到意向描描述的准确的让人拍案叫绝的一首诗。
[主播] 春江潮水连海平，海上明月共潮生。
[主播] 燕燕随波千万里，何处春江无月明。
[主播] 你注意，你注意它是个措辞。
[主播] 写的真好呀。
[主播] The moon over the river on a spring night.
[主播] 当然这个很长啊，后面我就不给大家全部读完了。
[主播] 因为后面这个大家都知道，比如说经典的说江畔何人初见月，江月何年初照人。
[主播] 人生代代无穷已，江月年年只相似。
[主播] 后面给你翻译的。
[主播] In spring, the river rises as high as the sea, and with the river's tide uprises the moon bright.
[主播] She follows the rolling waves for 10,000 li.
[主播] 里嘛，千里嘛，十万里啊，十千里就一万里。
[主播] Where the river flows, there overflows her light.
[主播] 许老师的翻译有的时候。
[主播] 你等一个味妆纸，我把桌子擦一下，我把书弄脏了。
[主播] 许老师的翻译呢，很多时候就是让人感觉到拍案叫绝。
[主播] 就是你也不知道他到底有怎么样灵巧的那个思路，他正好就在那块能想的那个词。
[主播] 晚辈愚钝啊。
[主播] 晚辈曾经在大学的时候也尝试。
[主播] 先给我一个诗经。
[主播] 我先擦诗再擦，这样子能干净。
[主播] 你这个就放在这里，OK。
[主播] 我曾经在大学的时候把许老的翻译看过无数遍。
[主播] 越看觉得越绝，越看越觉得我不行，真的不行。
[主播] 相思，王维。
[主播] 红豆生南国，春来发几枝，愿君多采撷，此物最相思。
[主播] 当然这首诗大家都听过，对吧？
[主播] 你听过王维的什么红豆吗？是吧？
[主播] 前一段相思嘛，是吧？
[嘉宾] 听过王维的相思。
[主播] 你听过王维的相思吗？
[主播] 前段时间好像这是一个梗，对吧？
[主播] 然后呢，这首诗也翻译的是真的好。
[主播] 说 The red beans grow in southern land, how many load in spring the trees.
[主播] Gather them to full as your hand, they will revive found memories.
[主播] 你看 spring the trees.
[主播] Revive found memories.
[主播] In southern land.
[主播] Is your hand.
[主播] 他把音压的就非常好。
[主播] 许老的这个唐诗宋词诗经一共现在有十万册。
[主播] 如果说之前没有拍到的朋友，请自己去拍一单。
[主播] 这三本书我是强烈建议每一个人家里都应该有一有意的。
[主播] 有一套的。
[主播] 它的好处在于什么？第一个，首先上面是这个古诗。
[主播] 大家可以看到孩子在家里没事的时候就可以先背诗。
[主播] 小的时候熟读唐诗三百首，不会作诗也能赢。
[主播] 先大量的去背，背的多了。
[主播] 他长大的时候就自然有了人文气息。
[主播] 大家这两天喜欢顿顿，张嘴就来。
[主播] 因为他有大量的记忆过，他有大量的输入呀。
[主播] 然后呢，下面你看还有这个对应的英文的翻译，这是许老的翻译。
[主播] 许老的翻译真的很经典啊。
[主播] 他经典到不可多得。
[主播] 很多时候我们去听许老的翻译，真的就是拍案叫绝。
[主播] 我我之前给大家应该分享过。
[主播] 我当年大学就一开始什么时候对许老的翻译开始感觉到就是晚晚辈真的愚鲁，一生可能难以忘忘记相背的时候。
[主播] 第一个拿听过那个叫道可道，非常。
[主播] 他不应该那样停顿啊。
[主播] 他不是道可道，非常道。
[主播] 他应该是道可道，非常道。
[主播] 不是普通的道理。
[主播] 然后许老师怎么翻译呢？
[主播] 叫做 truth can be known.
[主播] 说真理是可以被人知道的。
[主播] 对吧，后来格物致知啊。
[主播] 真理是可以被知道的。
[主播] 真理不知道是在你内心还是在这个外面嘈杂的时间动，但是总之啊，真理是可以被知道的。
[主播] Truth can be known.
[主播] But.
[主播] It may not be the well-known truth.
[主播] 你注意这就是翻译的灵巧啊。
[主播] 如果是故弄玄虚的人，他一定会让自己显得复杂高深一些。
[主播] 他一定遣词造句显得结句熬牙一些。
[主播] 有的那种复杂已经到了必轴自真的状态了。
[主播] 就有人觉得你看我这用词多么高级。
[主播] 我的句子多么的复杂。
[主播] But no, that's not the point of any composition, that's not the point of any translation or interpretation, okay?
[主播] To make words simple.
[主播] And you will make the language beautiful.
[主播] 就一定不是复杂让人感到美，我们说大道至简，谁给你说过大道至杂呢？
[主播] 复杂的东西是很难被人所理解的。
[主播] 就他精致的像一朵花，但他没有香那种感觉。
[主播] 所以你看道可道非常道说真理是可以被大家所知道的，但可能不是。
[主播] 为人所熟知的这个真理。
[主播] 我好多年前就看过许老翻译这块。
[主播] 我看完之后我觉得。
[主播] 就是你看他没有用复杂的词，对吗？
[主播] 他也没有给你用非常夸张的翻译，对吗？他没有故意用一些让人感觉到听不懂的东西，对吗？
[主播] 但是他却把这个意思传达的很清晰很准确。
[主播] 这就是比例。
[主播] 叫四两拨千斤。
[主播] 如果说中文是古文，我也把英文翻译的非常复杂，那反而可能就走错了。
[主播] 所以我后来在读英文或者看很多翻译的这个思路就真的是早些年受到许老的影响。
[主播] 所以。
[主播] 小时候受到好的美的影响，你长大就能真正的去审视美。
[主播] 语言就是一种美。
[主播] 这个世界的美有千万种，这个世界的美包括天体行星宇宙万物的美。
[主播] 我们皆是宇宙星辰的孩子。
[主播] 我们既然生如蝼蚁而美若星辰，美若神明。
[主播] 那星辰也美若神明。
[主播] 这个世界还有很多美，比如说大江大河，比如说山川湖泊的美。
[主播] 自然界的美，它往往是难以复制的。
[主播] 所以人为什么会亲自然性？
[主播] 因为微观到原子层面，我们跟他们都一样。
[主播] 这个世界还有很多的美，比如说花红柳绿，比如说草长鹰飞。
[主播] 人间三月天，牵你爱人的手去看春天的河边。
[主播] 我不知道你有没有真的去过春天的河边，万物焕发生机的样子。
[主播] 那种美可以是去年今日此门中，人面桃花相应红。
[主播] 是那种美。
[主播] 我们还有其他更多的美。
[主播] 比如说三餐四季，直短情长的美。
[主播] 比如说那种细腻，细碎，细小，但是常常让你暖心，安心，自活放心的那些美，也有可能。
[主播] 美还有一种就是刚才给大家所展示的这种语言的美。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 而且我第一次给大家提到许老师。
[主播] 我提到他那个翻译，就是好多年前在先外国语大学的图书管理头。
[主播] 我坐在医楼的地上，头顶的空调吹下来，我一开始我觉得很燥热。
[主播] 但读到那句翻译的时候，我突然觉得自己寒毛就起来了，因为我觉得这个翻译太牛了。
[主播] 就是大家听过的不爱红妆爱武装。
[主播] 因为那会我确实英语水平差的很远。
[主播] 叫 not to powder the face.
[主播] But to face the powder.
[主播] 他就把两个词动名词性互换就行了。
[主播] Powder大家学过。
[主播] 名词叫什么呀？
[主播] 粉末。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 那你是不是引申为比如说脸上涂的这种脂粉。
[主播] 脸上涂的这种脂粉是这个写吗？
[主播] 是这样脂粉是这样写吗？
[主播] 脂肪的脂是这样写吗？
[嘉宾] 嗯，是。
[主播] 脂粉。
[主播] OK,不好意思啊。
[主播] 我中文。
[主播] 脂粉或者说我们所说的火药其实也可以吧。
[主播] 那动词呢就叫做。
[主播] 给什么什么施粉。
[主播] 然后呢， face大家也学过。
[主播]  face什么意思啊？
[主播] 名词就做脸。
[主播] 对吧，或者什么的表面。
[主播] 比如说 the face of the earth,地球的表面。
[主播] 那动词呢就叫做面对。
[主播] OK, you're going to face difficulties in your life eventually.
[主播] 你肯定会在生活中面临很多的困难的。
[主播] 所以注意它的翻译。
[主播] 叫不要去给脸上涂脂粉，叫不爱红妆。
[主播] 而是去面对这个火药，叫爱武装。
[主播] 就很神。
[主播] 这就很神。
[主播] 所以这就是为什么这三本书需要值得你去买。
[主播] 好书值得买。
[主播] 好书甚至值得收藏。
[主播] 我觉得这几套书不仅你自己可以看。
[主播] 你自己甚至可以把它留给自己的子孙去看。
[主播] 这套书我们刚上第一天我就拍了，我拍了三套。
[主播] 我自己留了一套，我给别人也送了两套。
[主播] 比如说翻到这首像杜甫。
[主播] 李白的偶像谁？
[主播] 李白的偶像武将。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 十步杀一人。
[主播] 千里不流行。
[主播] 杜甫的偶像谁？
[主播] 杜甫的偶像诸葛亮。
[主播] 所以他写的属像大家都知道吧？
[主播] 丞相祠前何处寻，锦官城外柏森森。
[主播] 应接碧草自春色，隔夜黄里空好音。
[主播] 三顾频繁天下计，两朝开计老臣心。
[主播] 最后两句话大家都听过，叫做出身未捷身先死。
[主播] 常使英雄泪满襟。
[主播] Temple of the premier of the Shu, Shu就是蜀国啊。
[主播] Premier, it's like the prime minister, like the highest position in in a government.
[主播] It's kind of, yeah.
[主播] The premier's temple is in the shade.
[主播] Surprise woven with brocade.
[主播] The steps are green with grass in spring, in vain, a leaves or saying.
[主播] Consulted thrice on the state affair, he served two reigns beyond compare.
[主播] He died before he won success, could heroes tears now wet their dress.
[主播] 你看这个的翻译就美在哪呢？
[主播] 美在你看一句话里头就连续压两个音。
[主播] 你看前面是 shade,后面是 brocade.
[主播] Spring, orange, saying.
[主播] State affair, state affair就国家事务， state affair,后面叫做 beyond compare。
[主播] 单句里头前后两个短句压住，再下边是 one success.
[主播] wet their dress.
[主播] 精致不精致？
[主播] 760年春天，杜甫出至成都。
[主播] 探访诸葛武侯写下来这一首感人肺腑的千古绝唱。
[主播] 760年。
[主播] 那写完这首诗之后两年李白就去世了。
[主播] 李白是701年出生，762年去世。
[主播] 王维也一样，王维是701年同样在山西的这个。
[主播] 永济出生，然后在761年去世的。
[主播] 当然关于王维的这个出生年月份是有好几个学术界的争议的啊。
[主播] 有人说他是69几的出生的。
[主播] 前不见古人，后不见来者。
[主播] 翻译的特别好。
[主播] Where are the great men of the past? And where are those of the future years?
[主播] The sky and the earth forever last, here and now I alone shed tears.
[主播] 看 future years, shed tears, of the past, forever last.
[主播] 翻译的真好。
[主播] 黄河远上白云间，一片孤城万仞山。
[主播] 羌笛何须怨杨柳，春风不度玉门关。
[主播] 在古代你要出了玉门关就差不多就出了国了。
[主播] 玉门关阳关，对吧？
[主播] 西出阳关无故人。
[主播] 离的都很近。
[主播] 如果你从西安出发一路沿著这个丝绸之路开。
[主播] 其实都都很像，都离的都很近。
[主播] Out of the great wall,你看。
[主播] 就出了长城了吗？
[主播] 长城以内叫我们所守护的地方。
[主播] The Yellow River rises to the white cloud, the lonely town is lost and made the mountains proud.
[主播] Cloud, proud.
[主播] Why should the mango flute complain the willow grow beyond the gate of Jade, the wind will blow.
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 愿杨柳，为什么抱怨没有柳树在生长呢？后面说因为没有春风能够吹过来。
[主播] 对吧，好像我们小时候学的这杨柳的叶子细小都是吹风给从树枝里抽出来的一样。
[主播] 剪出来的一样。
[主播] 这就是翻译的这个灵巧之处啊。
[主播] 春风不度玉门关，就吹不到这里。
[主播] 太平洋的水气好像吹不到这里一样。
[主播] 今天晚上我们是不是有橄榄油啊？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 我昨天晚上睡著了。
[主播] 我觉得我今天晚上应该能写几个小作文。
[主播] 我今天晚上状态很好。
[主播] 你看出来吗？
[嘉宾] 可以，看得出来。
[主播] 能看出来是吧？
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 好，我再讲一会书，等我们人数到多的时候。
[嘉宾] 可以可以。
[嘉宾] 看看这几本你哪个想讲。
[主播] 活著。
[主播] 经典书目反复讲。
[主播] 如果说连这种经典的书我都推荐不出去，那说明我确实不够好。
[主播] 不是书不好。
[主播] 是学生的比例不到。
[主播] 是晚辈的能力不够。
[主播] 我们为什么要去审视苦难？
[主播] 因为我们要寻求美好。
[主播] 只有见过了黑暗的人才会渴望光明。
[主播] 只有身患重症的人。
[主播] 才尤其的渴望健康。
[主播] 只有经历挫折的人才懂得平淡是真。
[主播] 这就是为什么在现在生活感觉已经很好的时候，人们要去审视苦难。
[主播] 审视苦难的本质是让你知道如何过好自己这短暂的一生啊。
[主播] 当你的生命有一天感觉没有什么能够值得去寄托的时候，我们要如何继续前行？
[主播] 这一句话我认为可以比较从一个概括的角度去总结这本书。
[主播] 啊，家人一个一个离开。
[主播] 家产也散尽。
[主播] 自己就只剩下一个残缺的，疾病的，年迈的身体的时候。
[主播] 富贵要怎么过完他这一生？
[主播] 苦难的人会看到苦难。
[主播] 但透过苦难，人类会看到生命的底色。
[主播] 你会遇到不快乐嘛，对吧？
[主播] 我希望你快乐。
[主播] 然后呢，这个因为最近我火了，很多人把董宇辉当成一个关系很好的朋友，向他倾诉内心的这个愁苦。
[主播] 我其实收到很多的消息，但我真的第一个我看不完，第二个我也回不完。
[主播] 我前两天拿了手机，大家知道，因为我那个抖音睡一觉起来涨几十万粉丝。
[主播] 我们自从远古时代时期，人一直就在与苦难做斗争。
[主播] 睡一觉涨四五十万粉丝。
[主播] 但是，我始终相信人是一种充满了力量感的生物。
[主播] 都在给我发消息。
[主播] 我手机折叠打开抖音屏幕就变白了，就发烫，就关机了，就自动关机了。
[主播] 要不然我们也不可能坚持到今天。
[主播] 大家能理解在环境极度困难的时候。
[主播] 我姐姐应该是听到了，很心疼我，给我寄了一个新的手机过来。
[主播] 在生活极度艰难的时候。
[主播] 还挺感动的。
[主播] 在命运极其坎坷的时候。
[主播] 我这两天收到了好几个莫名的快递，挺感动的。
[主播] 我们总是能够想办法熬下来，对吧？
[主播] 然后我以为是，谁会买这么贵的东西，我姐说他买的。
[主播] 总是可以的，你说呢？
[主播] 我现在能打开了。
[主播] 总是可以的。
[主播] 我看了很多朋友跟我讲的故事。
[主播] 余华老师大家不知道吗？
[主播] 有的讲自己生意失败了，感觉人生一无是处的故事。
[主播] 许三观卖血记。
[主播] 没看过，活著没看过。
[主播] 有的讲，比如说自己的父亲因为生了重病，几天前离开了他的故事，他的人生。
[主播] 如果没有看过的话，大家请大家这个后来就。
[主播] 对，他曾经被改编过电影和电视剧，富贵们大家听过吧？
[主播] 好像一个飘在大海上的船。
[主播] 我我之前给大家讲过一个啊。
[主播] 他没有锚了。
[主播] 就是当你生命失无可失的时候，请你永远要坦坦荡荡的充满勇气的去过好自己这一生，不为别的，因为你的生命属于你自己。
[主播] 有的人跟我讲了。
[主播] 他自己就在医院里身患癌症，然后在化疗。
[主播] 今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 其实很多夸我的那种啊，董老师你真帅那种。
[主播] 这应该是海孩子写的一句诗，是吗？
[主播] 那种话反而我不会过多去看，因为我知道。
[主播] 我没有记错的话。
[主播] 今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 如果没有记错的话，应该是孩子写的诗。
[主播] 我知道我想给大家传递的是一种力量感。
[主播] 也许有一天生活很明媚的时候，当你目及之处皆是春光与美好的时候，那会儿你可能就不需要我了。
[主播] 今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 大家可以把这句话发在评论区，今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你。
[主播] 我总是一个苦大仇深的人，我总是一个心思细腻的人。
[主播] 但是在你人生难的时候，我觉得难得有人陪你。
[主播] 所以我特别希望刚才那句话能够今天温暖到你。
[主播] 今天我不爱世人，今天我只爱你。
[主播] 活着这本书，我在有一刻突然就特别体会到这个文章里头所讲的那种。
[主播] 那种活下去的勇气是什么？
[主播] 就是我之前给大家讲过，我我是在陕西生长的。
[主播] 我在那儿长大，虽然是很穷苦的农村生活。
[主播] 但至少家人给了我很好的教育和这个价值观的引导，他们从小鼓励我去感受自然，感受人的喜怒哀乐去读书，所以到现在虽然我。
[主播] 人生也受了很多苦，但是我至少能够清楚的表达自己的想法，我觉得很多人可能就是觉得我能把事情说清楚而已。
[主播] 除此之外我也没有什么优点。
[主播] 我小时候其实也抱怨过我家里，坦诚来说，我也抱怨过我家里。
[主播] 然后直到这个去年，就我跟你说去年五一，我开着车不是带着我爸妈回了一趟湖北老家吗？
[主播] 为什么我突然想给大家说这句话，今夜我不爱世人，今夜我独爱你，因为我们有太多的原因去脆弱了。
[主播] 对吗？去投降了。
[主播] 那个老家就是我爷爷小时候他从那儿过来。
[主播] Never surrender to the fate.
[主播] 他也没有在那儿生活过。
[主播] 今夜我不关心人类，我只想你。
[主播] 在去的路上可能才聊得很细致。
[主播] OK,OK,原话这么说的。
[主播] 不好意思啊。
[主播] 因为一路要穿过很多的大山，很高的悬崖。
[主播] 今夜我不关心人类，我只向你，是吧？
[主播] 嗯嗯。
[主播] 我说错了，孩子原是这个样子。
[主播] 今夜我不关心人类，我只向你。
[主播] 因为高速都是在那个悬崖之间绕来绕去。
[主播] 我爸说以前走就是走下面那个河滩。
[主播] 我觉得我刚是那个，我不爱世人，我只爱你，也行。
[主播] 经常下了大雨的时候，然后那个水突然就涨起来了。
[主播] 我觉得也挺好的。
[嘉宾] 是一种延伸。
[主播] 说我这个我爷爷的这个爸爸和妈妈当年就是挑个担保爷爷从湖北一直挑挑着担子走到了陕西老家。
[主播] 对不起，虽然我做错了，但是我这个将错就错。
[主播] 人生难得躺平，像我这种将错就错的，想得很开。
[主播] 然后说走着走着突然上游的大水冲下来了，把担子冲走了，两个老人就冲到河里头去把孩子抱出来，然后担子就被水冲走了。
[主播] 我为什么会这么说呢？因为。
[主播] 大家生活中这上会遇到不快了嘛，对吧？
[主播] 我希望你快乐。
[主播] 他们一共走了几个月，你想在大山深处连吃的都没有，那会儿孩子还在吃奶啊。
[主播] 然后呢，这个因为最近我火了，很多人把东西会当成一个关系很好的朋友，向他倾诉内心的愁苦。
[主播] 你想他们晚上睡在哪儿？我们甚至看到悬崖上有人把那个就当地那些人把那个棺材吊上去，塞到悬崖里那种。
[主播] 你见过那种吧？
[主播] 然后呢，你想以前那个自然环境比较好的时候，大家可能在大山深处甚至会见到野兽。
[主播] 对吧？会见到狼。
[主播] 我就一路慢慢的开着，我就听着我爸在后，坐在后排，然后就有一句没一句的跟我讲着。
[主播] 我那一路感觉是一个寻根之旅，我更觉得那是我一个精神得到洗涤的一个过程。
[主播] 我我很开心他能跟我讲那些。
[主播] 我我爷爷那代人老家在运西，在处于实验室。
[主播] 我我那一路的思绪就久久无法平静，我始终在想，我在想当时面对那样的苦难，他们是怎么坚持下来的呀？
[主播] 我在想。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我人生说多少难啊？
[主播] 不就是小时候家里穷点吗？上学整天被人看不起，挨几顿打，被欺负吗？
[主播] 喜欢的女孩子把我拒绝了好几次吗？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 董宇辉你听好，所以咱俩做兄妹。
[主播] 不就是自己在工作的时候好多年，对吧？很累吗？
[主播] 不就是身体有点差，睡眠有点差吗？
[主播] 不就是自己去年想不通，绕着北四环一圈一圈的转，回去写很多非主流的作文吗？
[主播] 我可以表达。
[主播] 我也可以诉苦。
[主播] 那是我的权利，因为我诉苦完之后内心舒服一点。
[主播] 但是最终还是要找到继续生活的勇气。
[主播] 你知道去年五一那趟的旅行真的太有意义了。
[主播] 其实我当时是有个幻想的破灭，因为我爸描述的老家其实是一个好像是一个名门望族，但其实你做盘都是特别普通的小乡村。
[主播] 然后他所描述的那个传了好代人那个牛皮纸的族谱在几十年前那场特殊的历史事件中被焚毁了。
[主播] 其实没有那么多的感觉。
[主播] 但是我那一路走回去却听他讲着，因为我真的看过了那一路过来的自然的，那种天险。
[主播] 我才感受到了那一代人活下去的勇气。
[主播] 于是我就理解了很多。
[主播] 所以我们时常要去感受这些，感受这些的目的并不是让你痛苦，而是让你重新。
[主播] 有勇气，有乐观，有智慧。
[主播] 抱怨谁不会啊？
[主播] 能憋住不抱怨才牛呢。
[主播] 放弃多容易啊？
[主播] 能坚持熬下去才牛呢。
[主播] 我们很多时候小时候在瞻仰英雄。
[主播] 长大之后呢。
[主播] 你其实也可以理解成为，你自己也可以成为英雄的。
[主播] 我没有记错的话，孩子应该还有一首诗，叫做你要什么什么什么，然后默不作声穿越整座城市。
[主播] 对不起，我忘了。
[主播] 就是默不作声穿越整座城市那个，你可以搜一下。
[主播] 我当时读完那那一段之后，就突然就有了很多的勇气。
[主播] 我觉得那一段的勇气就瞬间让人豁然开朗了。
[主播] 丹尼帮我搜一下那段。
[主播] 对不起啊，我。
[主播] 我忘了那一段了，我忘了那一段可能给大家体验不好啊。
[主播] 那段应该就是说你要默不作声穿越整座城市，大概是那么说的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 因为我知道这一两年大家可能受苦受的多了嘛。
[主播] 所以在人生难的时候，试着从世间万物中寻找勇气。
[主播] 可以是一本书，可以是与好朋友的一次聊天。
[主播] 可以是去大江大河里头去感受自然，感受生命的力量。
[主播] 也可以是回到老家里，虫鸣鸟叫里好好的睡一觉。
[主播] 是吧？可以。
[主播] 可以是任何东西。
[主播] 如果是这本书的话，你可以去看，如果不是这本书，你去其他地方寻找你的精神动力。
[主播] 抱怨多容易啊？
[主播] 诉苦是弱者的权利。
[主播] 我记得好多年前我在抱怨工作难做的时候，当时宋老师跟我说。
[主播] 这个骏马面前无沟壑。
[主播] 怂人面前全是坎儿。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 当然这句话把我清醒了好几天。
[主播] 丹尼刚搜到那句话了吗？
[嘉宾] 知道了。
[主播] 他怎么说的？
[嘉宾] 答应我忍住你的痛苦。
[嘉宾] 不发一言。
[主播] 是呃。
[嘉宾] 是孩子。
[主播] 是孩子是吧？
[主播] 答应我忍住你的痛苦，不发一言，穿过这整座城市。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 就很给人力量感，你知道很多文字的优点在哪里？就是。
[主播] 它不喧哗，不造作，但是它很给人力量感。
[主播] 答应我。
[主播] 什么？
[嘉宾] 不发一言。
[主播] 忍住痛苦。
[嘉宾] 穿过这整座城市。
[主播] 穿过这整座城市，对，我我记错了，不好意思啊。
[主播] 记忆力下降。
[主播] 对，当时宋老师跟我这样说，叫骏马面前无沟壑。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 沟壑怎么写？是这样写，对吧？
[主播] 沟壑，不好意思啊。
[主播] 骏马面前无沟壑，是吧？
[嘉宾] 是。
[主播] 怂什么叫怂呢？
[主播] 怂就是follow,跟随你的。
[主播] 内心。
[主播] 什么叫follow your heart?
[主播] 放弃是人性。
[主播] 认怂是人性。
[主播] 哭是人性。
[主播] 绝望是人性。
[主播] 但人为什么在修炼？
[主播] 人的修炼就是在自己的身上克服人性的缺点，在自己的身上克服这个时代。
[主播] 如果你总是第一时间顺从自己的内心。
[主播] 那就是认怂。
[主播] 怂就是遵从自己的心啊。
[主播] 与自己抗争。
[主播] 跟自己修炼。
[主播] 说怂人面前全是坎儿。
[主播] 他可能现在自己都不记得了。
[主播] 好多年前我听他说这句话。
[主播] 这是新东方甄选的直播间。
[主播] 东方甄选。
[主播] 我叫董宇辉，我是一个教了八年的高中英语老师。
[主播] 我今天心情很好。
[主播] 今天心情好的主要原因是因为我今天收到了很多我的学生给我的反馈。
[主播] 他们很开心。
[主播] 他说老师我英语考得很好。
[主播] 或者有孩子说老师我考得不怎么好。
[主播] 但我不纠结了。
[主播] 我人生无憾了。
[主播] 我高中努力过。
[主播] 我特别害怕他们把胜负看得特别重，我特别害怕他们把结果看得特别重，以至于患得患失啊。
[主播] 所以我其实认识他们几年，我一直给他们说。
[主播] 结果不重要。
[主播] 内心无愧才重要。
[主播] 就像你终将离开这个城市，离开这个世界，你重要的只是你怎么样过好这一生。
[主播] 有孩子跟我说老师可能我没有期待中那么好。
[主播] 但是我内心无憾了。
[主播] 就像老师经常所说的，得到的是得到的叫青春，错过的叫人生。
[主播] 不一定总非得得偿所愿。
[主播] 人生有时候的美好就在于阴差阳错。
[主播] 阴差阳错的才能去那些城市，才能见那些人啊。
[主播] 阴差阳错的才能展开一段奇旅。
[主播] 阴差阳错的后来你才能去新东方当一个老师，阴差阳错的当了一个老师之后你才教了50万的学生。
[主播] 阴差阳错的你后来才能站在屏幕前卖菜。
[主播] 给别人落落大方的讲你的故事。
[主播] 对不起，我这次讲活着吧，活着讲成了这样子。
[主播] 但是我相信每个人也从我这里，文字里能够感受到我想传递的力量。
[主播] 当然这样讲有卖出去吗？
[嘉宾] 卖了四千多本。
[主播] 啊，卖的不好是吧？
[嘉宾] 还行，挺好。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 行，还是得写小作文。
[主播] 咱今天晚上卖橄榄油是吧？
[主播] 西班牙的橄榄油是吗？
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 安达卢西亚那个地方是吧？
[主播] 好。
[主播] 来，把油给我。
[主播] Extra virgin olive oil。
[主播] 特级初榨橄榄油的意思就是。
[主播] 橄榄果摘下来24小时之内就榨了。
[主播] 鲜。
[主播] 所以口感好。
[主播] 国外进的油，回来罐装。
[主播] 酸度很重要。
[主播] 好的油酸度就比较低。
[主播] 当然自然榨出来的酸度低，有的人他是通过后期的这个化学手段故意把酸度降低，那不算。
[主播] 国标是小于等于0.8%。
[主播] 我们的酸度是小于等于0.6%。
[主播] 口感风味营养得到很大的保存。
[主播] 原产国是西班牙。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 我好多年前去过西班牙。
[主播] 想到了我准备写小作文了啊。
[主播] 大家想录的朋友可以准备好。
[主播] 看现在几点。
[主播] 8点55。
[主播] 我要不要整到9点？
[主播] 想到西班牙，我首先想到的是马德里的艺术馆。
[主播] 我在里头看到过达利的作品。
[主播] 我想到的是那些穿越了历史，仍然停留的宫殿。
[主播] 呃。
[主播] 我想到巴塞罗那，我想到地中海的海岸。
[主播] 想到了灌在杯子里的桑格利亚。
[主播] 和端到你面前的海鲜饭。
[主播] 我想到了安达卢西亚，它是西班牙最南部，也是欧洲最南部的一个城市。
[主播] 它与直布罗陀海峡呢。
[主播] 紧邻着。
[主播] 所以直布罗陀海峡将欧洲与非洲切断。
[主播] 直布罗陀海峡很宽啊。
[主播] 虽然我们无法跨越天险。
[主播] 虽然我们无法跨越天险，但我还是想牵你的手。
[主播] 把景色尽览。
[主播] 哎，压上来。
[嘉宾] 是的。
[嘉宾] 但呀。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 差不多。
[主播] 我刚刚再重来一遍，我刚刚说了啥？
[主播] 当我想到西班牙。
[主播] 我想到的是。
[主播] 不好意思，变，重说第二遍，变不住了。
[主播] 当我想到西班牙，我想到的是。
[主播] 马德里的艺术馆。
[主播] 我想到了达利的话作。
[主播] 和穿越时光的宫殿。
[主播] 我想到了巴塞罗那。
[嘉宾] 海鲜饭。
[主播] 阳光撒落的地中海岸。
[主播] 我想到了成满杯子的桑格利亚。
[主播] 以及端到你面前的海鲜饭。
[主播] 我想到了安达卢西亚。
[主播] 那是欧洲的最南端。
[主播] 直布罗陀海峡将欧洲与非洲隔断。
[主播] 我身为凡人，虽无法带你跨越天险，但我仍愿牵你的手。
[主播] 将景色变蓝。
[主播] 大概是这个样子。
[嘉宾] 加会员会有优惠。
[主播] 点击屏幕中间，加入东方甄选的抖音会员店。
[主播] 里头有券，可以用券去买啊。
[主播] 我们的自营品是。
[嘉宾] 给大家用券去购买。
[主播] 安达卢西亚为什么这个地方很牛呢？因为它是就是西班牙的南嘛，它隔着海，隔着海岸对面就已经是非洲了。
[主播] 所以它跟那个海岸，那个海峡就是直布罗陀海峡。
[主播] 因为是直布罗陀海峡，所以仍然它其实是一种地中海气候。
[主播] 地中海气候的特点是啊，就是冬天呢，温度偏暖。
[主播] 夏天其实会有。